okay next game I've got good white again
playing against a Dutch player think
happy ending now we gotta learn English
symmetrical English with five let's see
em Howard continues usually black here
goes for g63 797 this kind of setup so
it tries to play before of course now on
the white knight sm Maru 2 e 3 yr c 2 e
3 to d5 to get the best possible
controller of the d5 square case playdom
immediate f5 maybe it is an idea to
flick nd3 idea to maybe make it more
difficult fame to go f form and also
intending Bishop g5 he didn't do
anything about this I play I play the
smooth I think I'm okay he ignored the
positional threat here surprisingly
usually black shouldn't allow this kind
of exchange because now i get very nice
piece control of d5
yeah this is interesting known for play
Bishop 35 I'll get this brilliant light
should be five but of course my light
squared Bishop is somewhat missing I go
anywhere with this yeah of course is
what some was clear interesting maybe
Knight c3 to be 5 i'm not sure i don't
want to take it wouldn't be bad
necessarily and okay just I just take
and every Queen sees see 234 not sure
what what you play Queen B ate something
it could even play before then exchange
everything and then no okay I think
let's let's stay with a simple approach
here maybe roots the age I didn't didn't
think about this move this could be a
could be annoying hmm it is annoying and
okay this was bad shouldn't have allowed
this it's maybe not not a big deal but
still the zone this could have been
avoided
he just play screen b7 okay I want to
anchor tonight anyway so some no big
deal and now should should get this pawn
back anyway yep okay Annie to maybe just
all the way back to f1 ensure an hour to
an order to cover this have to scram it
looks silly somewhat ok doesn't play for
when ok can you give Lee repeat once at
least
see if he wants to do something with the
extra minute okay just here may be okay
either then then you could take and play
mp3 I could take with the pawn I could
tip with a pawn here yeah maybe just
just move right it would be a would be
very nice to get rid of I'm the heavy
pieces here at least them of course I
need to get the porn backward turn to
sugar should try to exchange the heavy
piece of center get the spawn back then
it should be a pretty pretty good
endgame for me it's still somewhat
tricky of course here with the tactical
motives but now I should just threaten
to to take before
he still has got this um this very very
ineffective boom so this is the big deal
me if I've got the phone if I'm left
with a knight on d5 and he could take
now play b3 you are today I'm really not
playing here I'm not focused enough here
really this is stupid I shouldn't have
allowed this really stupid the ads it's
so long so difficult for black to to get
anything here but um this was of course
not turn not necessary at all yeah night
h6 to see one could be as idea
I've got this covered owned by one leg
doesn't have great ideas here he's
somewhat tied 2-2 the b3 porn okay I'm
titled tweed it as well but it sounds
looks difficult to to make progress not
sure what the Sun this was all about
okay so we can make inside somewhat but
I don't get it wonder what's this I can
just like and just take me three now
yeah but this is just just okay now for
me he won't get anything on wrecking
here I'll get something side to check
everything based on age five my night is
also just just the better piece here
before no no also um look b7 coming up
in order no I don't want to want to
exchange Queens so easily
okay maybe Quincy forum twinsies for to
f1 as an idea I go h5 now we have three
h5 threatened I don't mind if you play
so cringy for something yeah and made
neck smooth black yeah strange game of
course an turn also bad game I
completely I didn't get get truck c8
forgot about this move and this was
really someone annoying not easy to get
the porn back but still it is it's
fairly solid I don't think um like ass
got anything to great iam yeah I just
played awful why why not did I did I
allow this here no I mean I've in this
position would be three it should be
shouldn't be allowed but okay it said
it's not easy because black has got
those two pieces on b7 and b5 he always
needs to protect me 3 i'm attacking into
x not sure how he should really make
some some easy progress it's maybe it's
not that easy to to get something here
maybe black needs to rely on some great
tricks or something of the computer
actually gives it as completely equal
completely equal you know yeah maybe
it's not it's not not easy i think this
is just a stupid piece on g7 compared to
the modern
five yeah well at least the wynfrey ok
next one